- Today are going to talk
about what an average work week
looks like in the life
of a strategy consultant.
Welcome to another coffee
break here on my channel
Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich on this
channel I want to help you
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
I worked as strategy consultant
for the consulting firm
McKinsey for about six years.
And as you can imagine
I did lots of projects
throughout that time.
Today, I'm talking about how
a typical work week look like
and I have to say that this is a work week
before the current health situation.
So it reflects our typical
work week look like up until
about early this year and hopefully
how it will look like soon again.
So to walk you through
a typical work week,
I will now look down here on my screen
where I prepared a schedule for you.
A work schedule for you
how this week looks like.
Let's start with Monday.
Monday is travel day.
Usually you will fly in
from your office location
to the client on Monday.
When exactly the flight goes depends a bit
on the flight schedule but
also your team preferences.
I had studies.
I have projects where I needed
to take a 6:00 AM flight
in the morning on Monday
that of course is quite brutal
and can lead to you needing
to wake up at 4:00 AM every Monday.
I would say average is getting
a flight around 7:00 AM
7:30 AM but instead
those might require you
to stand up quite early
based on where you live.
Then next, once you are at the client,
it is quite common to do
something like a check in
and check out every day with your team.
So here are your team
lead we'll come together
with a whole team, sometimes all together,
sometimes with everybody individually
and then talk to him what his
priorities are for the day
and then also at the checkout
at the end of the day,
what the associates
still have on their plate
also to help them
prioritize if he realizes
that maybe one guy really
has lots of stuff to do
which maybe isn't even required
on that specific evening.
Then you will often have
a weekly client check-in.
So you will sit together
with your main client,
with your main contact person.
You will look into the
whole work week with firms,
set the priorities for
the week, adjust the line
and do a quick check in with them.
Afterwards, if you have some
time you will meet for lunch.
So if the client has a nice canteen,
you will often sit together
there with your team
and just have some lunch and
then after that frequently,
you will sit together and
interviews with clients.
So these can be all kinds
of interview situations
says on the type of projects that you do.
For instance, maybe a
finance guy from the client
sent you some data end of last week
and now you want to sit with them,
go over the data with them
and ask some clarifying
questions that you might have.
Then you have a bit of
spare time where you sit
in the team room, to get some work done
and to do the checkout.
Then after the checkout if
it's a bit of a more slow day
than often, you can then
jointly with the team,
drive to your hotel and you
might have a nice dinner
in the hotel restaurant
and then after dinner,
you go to your room and get some work done
from your hotel room and
here now in this example day,
you would be done at 10:00
PM with all your emails,
with everything.
This is then where you can
really shut down your laptop
and being completely finished at 10:00 PM
is probably one of the better days.
10:00 PM, we would have
considered it go day
if you're completely done
and finished on the day
and can really now watch a movie
or do something completely
odds after 10:00 PM.
Then for the rest of the
week, you will often already
have some things locked
into your calendar.
For instance, the daily
check-ins and check out,
this is something that you will
usually do every single day
and then on Thursday and on Friday,
you might do the checkout
a bit earlier on Thursday
to enable the team then to fly out
back to the office location and
on Friday to enable the team
to get out into the weekend
maybe slightly earlier.
When exactly the check
in is so when you are
in the team room, this often
deviates a bit team by team.
So usually what I've experienced
is that around 9:00 AM
is you do the check-in but
then people already come
into the team room
around 8:00 AM to 8:30 AM
to already get some first work done
and prepare the day a bit.
Next you might also
have some internal calls
already scheduled.
So one thing that you will
usually have once or twice
every week something called
a team problem solving
where you sit together
with the whole team.
Often, also one of the
partners is flying in
joining you for the day,
sometimes also only by telephone
and where you then discuss
your progress with the partner.
You discuss some challenges
that you are facing,
some things where you need his input on
and try to solve certain problems
that the client might be facing.
Another thing that you were
frequently do are so called
internal expert calls so you
frequently look for experts
in your own consulting organization.
So these are often more senior consultants
that have already worked
on a specific topic
several times in the past
and then you talk to them
and you try to get their input on,
what they are best practice is,
what they believe how
your clients should solve
certain problems.
Then you will also have some other
prescheduled client meetings.
So frequently you have a weekly draw fixed
with the whole client team
where you sit together
with the whole team
discussing the progress
and then often every second week or so,
you have the steering committee
also called the Steerco.
And this is usually the most
important meeting for you
in the week because this
is where you present
your project progress
to your project sponsor
on the client side and this
is often a board member.
At least one board member present
sometimes even the whole board
or several board members present
and this is then really the
peak of the whole work week.
The key deliverables where you
sit together with the clients
and you show them what your resides
are at this point in time.
Well this being clear, then on Tuesday,
you come into the team
room, you have the check-in
and you conduct the Jour Fixe.
For the Jour Fixe, you might
have prepared a document
last Monday night and
then after the Jour Fixe
maybe you just meet with another person
in the client organization
to just discuss some data
or some other questions
that you might have.
Then you have the team problem solving
and here usually in such a week,
you're focused on the Steerco documents.
Focus on the document
that you will present
to the Steerco on Thursday.
And then frequently, now the partner
would have some suggestions,
some things he asks you
to implement in the document
and then he will ask you for a new meeting
on Wednesday afternoon
to discuss the things
that you're not asked to
do on the Steerco document.
Then afterwards, what
we at least at McKinsey
always try to do something
called sports Tuesday
where you try just to block
some time for the whole team
to do some sports and often also
we did some group activities.
You of course, what you do
depends a bit on your location,
what the possibilities are
so what we did for instance,
was renting a soccer place
where we were playing
some soccer as a team
or doing some CrossFit with a trainer
or just some team running,
just whatever the team fancied
and then after day like that,
everybody would just go
to his room frequently
and then just have dinner
for himself on the hotel room
and then just some last work
that everybody was doing for himself.
Next Wednesday, the same drill
you get into the team room,
you do your check in
and then you might meet
with your key project
lead from the client side
because often then the
clients have a project leaders
where you forward the project
that you're working on
and often in the steering committees,
you want actually the client
to present the documents
to not make it a consulting presentation
but rather presentation
that is really owned
by the client as well.
This of course requires that you align
the whole presentation with the client
and who you often run into situations
where you actually you as
a team would like to put it
in a certain way but for whatever reason,
the client wants to have
things done a bit differently
so then you sit together with them,
you discuss and then you do
some changes on the document.
Then you have the internal expert call
and then have some time
to get some more work done
before you talk to your
partner about the document.
Unfortunately, what
frequently happens is that
maybe you as a team you
believe that document
is just perfect that
you're completely done
but then the partner looks at it
and now he tells to that he
has a completely different
opinion that actually wants to do it
the completely different way
and now you're really facing
situation that you actually
need to send out the
document on that evening
so for the meeting next day
but now you suddenly realize that shoot,
you really have lots of stuff to do.
And what you also maybe have
seen that maybe on Tuesday
and Wednesday, there wasn't enough time
to have a proper lunch.
People might have just
done a quick working lunch
or even skipped lunch entirely
just to get the work done.
So here is where because now you realize
that you have all the
stuff to do you just do
a very quick dinner in the team room
maybe you order some pizza
and then the whole team
sits together in a crunch
to really finish now
the Steerco doc based on
all the inputs that you got
both from your partner
but also from the client
in the morning and all
this can then easily
take you up until 1:00 AM at
night or sometimes even later.
So this doesn't happen every
day but these days exist
and unfortunately, at
least from my experience,
they exist a the bit more often
than you might have hoped for.
And then next day even though
you're already stressed
and didn't have a lot of sleep,
at least I often try to prioritize sports.
So for me, it was important
to always have at least
two units of sports during the work week.
So what I would do often
try is then just put in
a little run at least in
the morning independent
of how long I worked last night okay.
That was just my commitment
to keep me happy.
But then later we would
go into the team room,
get some last work done, check-in
then the steering committee took place
and here then often other partners fly in,
the board members fly in
and for me it was always
an atmosphere a bit like
sitting in an exam, right.
So you did all this study
and then the big meeting is
and then hopefully it
went really way far better
maybe even then you hope for
and then everybody is happy
and know that just imagine
that this is what happened here as well
then you maybe sit together, have lunch,
the partners there as well,
you can talk a bit with them
then you maybe have
another client discussion,
then some more work, then check out
and then you call it a day.
So it was a good successful work week
because the Steerco went
well, everybody will be happy
and then you travel out.
You fly out.
When exactly you fly out
also often a bit depends
just on the habits of the team
but of course also your
flight connections.
So I'd say if I fly
out around five or six,
this would be rather early.
If you fly out after eight,
this would be rather late.
So something between
is what we usually had
and often frequently
you just book a flight,
you have it on standby because
you have flex tariffs.
So you can all the time
reschedule your flight.
Sometimes even after the
flight has already departed.
So you will often just log into flight
put in there for whatever reason
you need to take a later one
that you've just called your
travel team, you rescheduled it
and then just take a later one.
Then Thursday evening at home you really,
there's not that much
stuff there is to do.
Usually you then after you arrived,
maybe just write some emails
but then can call it a day.
And then on Friday you either
work from your home office
or from the actual office.
Here the culture might
differ a bit in between
the different MBB Firms, what is expected,
at least at McKinsey was
always completely fine
to pretty much always work from
the home office on Fridays.
This is what you wanted to do.
The only exception might've been,
if your project lead
came from the same office
where you are from that he
might ask yours to come in,
to sit with them on the
Friday in the office.
Then Friday often was a little bit slower.
You did some work but then
often you also had some time
to do admin tasks or participate
in any other office activities.
So this can be grabbing a coffee
with someone other colleagues,
some other fun activities in the office
or often just doing your
expenses on a Friday.
Then again, usually between five to six,
we had the checkout on Friday
and then often you're able
ready to leave the office
at 6:00 PM and then call it a day
and then start into the weekend.
Now regarding the weekend,
this was something I really
enjoyed in consulting
especially if you compare
it to investment banking
and this is that at least at McKinsey,
there was a very strong culture
that the weekend is free.
You're really not expected to do any work
on the weekend at all.
There might be some specific instances
where there's really a hard business need
where this is really
required and then yes,
you will be asked to work on the weekend
and this is all is expected from you
but this to me in my six years
really only happened a couple of times.
Most of the times I was
really completely free
and didn't do anything.
What some people do like to
do is that then on Sunday
evening they take some
time prepare the week
but this was something
most cases I rather did
in the taxi Monday morning
or maybe even in the plane.
So this isn't really required
if you don't wanna do that.
So that's it guys.
This is a typical work week.
So probably just also to put
this a bit in perspective,
this is not one of the lighter weeks
but this is also not
one of the hardest weeks
that you can face, right.
This is probably something in between
and usually the weeks
where you have Steercos
or the Steerco weeks are a bit tougher
because you are into lots of pressure
of getting the document out and then off,
there are all these last
minute changes and inputs.
So in this context, I would consider it
a representative week in MBB consulting.
Hope that was clear, if you
have any questions on that,
please leave me a comment
below in the comment section.
I'm very happy to engage
in the conversation
with all of you about
what I discussed today.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to this channel
and turn on the notification bell
to stay up to date on my content.
If you want to see even more from me,
also follow me on my Instagram,
my handle is @FirmLearning
and I also have a mailing list
where I share even more content with you.
You can find a sign up
linked to the mailing list
in the video description below.
Thank you for watching.
I very much appreciate your time.
My name is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
I release new videos every Saturday.
So would love to see you
again here on this channel
next Saturday and until
then have a good weekend.
Cheers guys.